face aux politiques nationales l'union
européenne réaffirme sa position
les dirigeants européens ont rappelé à
l'issue d'un sommet tenu en
visioconférence leur projet d'avancer
ensemble
l'objectif contre une nouvelle vague de
l'épidémie de kovy 19 avec une politique
commune près d'un an après les premiers
confinement lui sait qu'elle doit faire
face à une crise sanitaire mais aussi
sociale les citoyens sont de plus en
plus fatigués du coc vide et l'année a
été très éprouvante mais nous ne devons
pas relâcher nos efforts maintenant note
on est à spa situé non seulement la
situation reste grave dans de nombreuses
régions d'europe mais nous devons aussi
faire attention aux variants qui se
répandent
il ya donc beaucoup de défis à relever
devant nous en face ce jeudi l'union
européenne a rappelé que les efforts de
ses pays membres doivent être uniforme
dans la stratégie de vaccination un plan
pour faire face à la montée en puissance
des variants notamment britanniques
confiante quant à la distribution des
prochaines doses par les laboratoires
lieu veut vacciner une grande partie de
la population nous sommes convaincus que
nous sommes capables d'atteindre notre
objectif qu'à la fin de l'été nous
aurons vacciner 70 % de la population
adulte vaccination ce sont 255 millions
de personnes dans l'union européenne et
si nous regardons nos prévisions c'est
un objectif que nous nous savons
capables d'atteindre outre les vaccins
l'union européenne veut également
simplifier les déplacements à
l'intérieur de son territoire mais doit
faire face aux mesures locale de chaque
pays qui tentent d'endiguer l'épidémie
avec une fermeture de ses frontières
une épine dans le pied pour les
dirigeants européens qui prônent une
circulation plus fluide
concernant les voyages nous devons
respecter la proches communes dont nous
avons convenu les déplacements non
essentiels peuvent toujours être soumis
à des restrictions
mais les mesures doivent être
proportionnées et nous devons assurer la
circulation des biens et des services
dans le marché unique en utilisant les
voies de circulation dite verte
je fais confiance à la commission pour
veiller à ce que ces principes soient
respectés les avis des dirigeants
européens divergent cependant à propos
d'un possible passeport vaccinale et des
pays dont le tourisme est primordial
pour leurs économies comme chypre où la
grèce veulent une adoption rapide de ce
passeport une possibilité aussitôt
réfutée par berlin et paris qui juge une
inégalité de traitement
emmanuel macron prenant pas sanitaire
basé sur des tests négatifs récent
attire tout de suite l'attention sur le
fait que quand je dis pas sanitaire
c'est que ça ne peut pas être soumis au
vaccin
parce que si on arrive à un moment dans
le printemps à rouvrir certains de ces
lieux
nous ne saurions conditionné leur accès
à une vaccination alors même que nous
n'aurions même pas ouvert la vaccination
aux plus jeunes d'entre nous ferait
invraisemblable les vingt-sept ont
finalement confié à la commission
européenne la tâche d'élaborer les
conditions d'un certificat vaccinale
avec pour objectif de synchroniser les
systèmes de santé et les structures
douanières de chaque pays
mais angela merkel a assuré le passeport
vaccinale ne signifiera pas que ses
détenteurs seront les seuls à pouvoir
voyager